Um,
hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And I'm checking in on you,
although the way I was just coughing,
you should be checking in on me.
What do you think?
Hey,
what,
are you smoking?
A bunch of guys who had built?
No,
I'm not.
I was just,
uh,
just,
I got a little sick.
I got a little sick but not in tired.
I just got a little sick.
I just wrapped on my general hospital,
my 72 episode arc on General Hospital,
um,
12 hour days,
six days a week.
And uh,
we knocked it out and I actually got to see a sneak peek of the,
obviously it's not journal hospital.
I got to see the sneak peek of this thing that I'm going to be a small part of.
As always,
I always pair a troop into things that are really cool.
I'm never the main guy.
All right.
That,
that,
that's not the road from me.
You know,
I'm a bald,
redheaded male.
Okay.
I know the deal.
I'm in the background.
I get it.
All right.
You know,
you don't see me cold complaining like some of these fat chicks out here in
Hawaii and I almost said Hawaii out here in Hollywood.
Like,
oh,
how come I'm not start in a,
in a,
in a fucking movie because you look like me with a dress.
That's why.
Okay.
And people invest money and they want to make it back.
So at some point you're going to have to deal with the fact that you know,
you're in the van,
man.
All right?
You're not picking the fucking safe.
The lock on the safe.
Anyways,
we rapped on it.
I had a great time.
I took some chances as an actor,
I learned some things.
Um,
I,
I learned what I always learned whenever I go on a shoot like that.
Just the sheer,
the sheer amount of fucking work,
how hard everybody works on those things.
And it just kills me whenever these politicians never,
these politicians run for office.
Who Do they talk about?
Did they talk about people busting their asses?
Like people who fucking write scripts and people got to figure out how to then,
you know,
fucking shoot the thing and all these different looks.
And now way talk about Joe six pack
Joe six pack.
Fucking putting his pants on one leg at a fucking time.
He's got time to go drink a fucking six pack,
you know,
some fucking dope.
Just driving around in an era in a,
you know,
I don't know why no fucking ice cream truck is getting more love from the next
potential president of the United States.
The,
that somebody has got to stand there holding a fucking microphone over some ball
jackass like me for 12 hours a day.
I don't know.
I think these politicians of rock,
maybe if all these fucking Hollywood people would quit shitting on half of them,
maybe the hardworking people in the movie industry,
we get a little more love.
It's just,
just,
I'm just thinking out loud here,
people.
Um,
anyways,
I had a fucking awesome time and I got to work with some amazing actors and uh,
you know,
just great storytellers and all that and I had a great fucking time.
Having said that,
I'm old and I'm exhausted.
Um,
all right.
And I gotta jump on a red eye tonight to go out,
fly direct to fuck in Atlantic city.
Um,
cause I'm doing a Gig at the board.
Got It.
Tomorrow night.
All right.
I'm taking off my acting hat and I'm putting on my standup shirt.
Um,
anyway,
speaking of shirts,
did anybody see that stupid sweater Gucci made?
I'm getting all my news from Twitter by the way.
I've just given into the fact that I'm not going to be an informed person.
All right.
You're listening to the wrong bill.
Okay?
You want to listen to Bill Maher if you want,
if you want to listen to somebody who knows what the fuck is going on,
okay?
You want to listen to that bill?
All right?
You want to listen to some shit at who reads hashtags or in whatnot.
You're listening to the right podcast.
All right.
Gucci sweater.
One of these fucking idiots,
right,
goes out and he designs his fuck.
He or she all right was either some dumb guy or a strong brave woman.
Is that my,
is that how you supposed to say it politically?
Um,
designed a turtle neck that was black that you feel whatever stupid fucking
reason you pulled up over like right up underneath your nose and then your,
your mouth came through it.
And then there was these big red lips around it.
Yeah.
So if you seen the picture,
just Google a picture of it.
All right.
African American people,
you know,
not all of them.
I don't even know how many,
I don't,
I didn't take a fucking sense of start going.
Jesus Christ,
can we stop with the fucking black face is offensive.
You know,
they said the sweater look like it was black faces and they immediately made it
about themselves rather than the real issue,
which was that it was an unbelievably ridiculous and ugly fucking turtleneck
sweater.
That's all it was.
It was an ugly turtleneck sweater or you know,
and I don't,
I don't want to get involved in a racial debate here,
but as a privileged white male,
I want you to know that I was triggered by the fact that all those black people
ignored the fact that there was also half of white face behind that turtleneck.
Okay.
And how do you think I felt to not feel represented
in that sweater scandal?
Yeah.
Um,
is it a fucking amazing,
the shit that just get light somehow gets traction on social media?
You know,
what about the fucking eight year old,
you know,
who usually goes to bed at three in the morning after?
So in those fucking things together in some sweatshop now we had to stick around
for an extra half hour to,
so the extra fucking thread to make sure it went up and over your mouth.
Right.
And then what happens?
Everybody in the first world country makes it all about themselves.
And everybody forgets about that little fucking kid there.
Right?
Little fucking Joe,
a six pack,
right?
MMM.
I Dunno,
my wife is really into fashion.
I so much of it is just ugly Shit,
you know?
And then they just have some beautiful woman walked down the,
the,
the runway,
like looking confident,
you know.
But that one,
I swear to God,
that was like something out of the muppets,
wasn't it?
I was like the dumb Donald fucking no dump.
Donald had a hat pulled down over his fucking,
I used to know all the fucking Cosby kids who was weird.
Harold,
one of them had a sweater yanked up over its face right over.
It's,
well,
it's a cartoon,
right?
Hold on a second.
Fat Albert kids.
Who were they?
Let's see,
what did you have?
What did you have images?
Um,
there was one.
Was it weird Harold?
No,
didn't one of them.
I guess they didn't.
It was Russell,
Rudy
blocky bill dumped Donald Weird Harold.
Yeah.
When was the last one?
Mush mouth.
One of those fucking cartoons had somebody with a thing yanked up over its face.
I had,
I don't fucking remember.
Um,
anyways,
that was a big scandal.
Everybody.
That was a big fucking scandal,
you know,
but thank God people spoke out.
And those sweaters will not be mass produced.
So whatever ones that they have will now be thrown into the ocean and we'll let
the poor pluses in dolphin steel with it,
you know?
I mean it could have kept a lot of half the lower half of a lot of people's
faces warm,
you know,
they easily could have died.
It,
you know,
made it a different color.
I then,
and then what?
Then you get Asians and
native Americans start fucking complaining.
It's just a bad idea.
I think that's what we learned this week.
You know,
you can't get mad at somebody for trying.
I mean it was a turtle neck sweater.
What the fuck can you do with it?
Can you lower it a little bit?
It's already been done.
Mock turtleneck sweater.
What do we do?
Well,
let's fucking,
let's keep it going.
What do you think?
Underneath the mouth?
No,
right up and over it.
That looks weird.
I'll put some fucking lips on it.
You know,
if you're sitting there going like bill,
who the fuck talks about half a turtle neck?
Fucking black face sweater for fucking eight minutes.
Well,
you know what,
it's not football season anymore.
Football season is over.
MMM.
Then you're in New England patriots and your New England patriots,
other fucking champion,
your Boston red sox or the world series champion and it's unbelievable.
You know Bruins are playing.
All right.
I don't know what's going on with the Celtics.
Somebody asked me today on set the way,
is Kyrie Irving going to go to the Lakers?
This kind of a room?
I heard of rule.
I have no idea.
All I know is I don't think that they've been playing as well as everybody
thought they were going to play,
so I have no idea.
But I'm going to try to check in on that.
All I have to do now,
now that I'm on the other side of that acting Gig,
all right.
All I gotta do now,
you know,
I keep doing the F is for family stuff and at night I'm just going to be running
my hour because I am taping my hour special.
I kind of kept it under wraps as to where I was taping it,
where I was recording it.
And I feel like now is the time,
you know,
cause it's a very weird time in comedy.
You hear that a lot now is not the time for those jokes.
I'm a white woman who's not even funny and I'm telling you that now is not the
time for that.
Have you noticed that most people who are saying what you should and shouldn't
be saying comedically are about as funny as your average feature act.
They're like Middle Act,
funny telling like fucking really funny people.
What they should be saying.
Um,
Oh yes.
Yes.
You by all means who with your best joke.
You just make me raise my eyebrows a little bit like yeah,
that was a funny,
wasn't it?
By all means.
Tell the world what is funny.
Um,
I am going to be recording my next hour special
and um,
Royal Albert Hall in London.
That's right.
I'm a trader.
I'm going back to the motherland.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
I mean I'm on my sixth one.
I've got to try something different.
I'm going to go over there,
be funny.
Half of my shit.
People will be like,
I don't understand that.
And maybe they'll bomb for part of it.
We'll see if it's funny.
Anyways,
I'll be doing it at Royal Albert Hall on a Monday and Tuesday.
March.
Uh,
what the fuck is that?
Third and fourth.
Fourth and fifth.
Fifth and sixth.
Yeah.
So I'm going to be doing a run of dates out here.
Um,
my,
I do the Borgata the fuck month is this.
Oh,
that's October.
Why is this an October
is the last time I actually put anything in my calendar.
October 29th I put Jimmy Kimmel.
How the fuck do I get out of this?
Click on this today.
Click on today.
All right,
here we go.
I'm sorry.
March.
Yeah,
March 4th and fifth.
All right,
so next week on the 15th,
16th and 17th,
I'll be in Santa Barbara.
I'll be in Pasadena and I'll be,
uh,
in,
Riverside,
California.
And then I go to New York City on the 19th and a,
I do the Patrice O'Neal benefit.
And then,
um,
I'm in New York for a little bit,
doing some spots out there and then I embark on a little run of dates through
the,
a great United Kingdom,
Great Britain,
whatever the fuck you call it.
And then I ended up at,
um,
okay.
I ended up a Royal Albert Hall and they have it.
And then when I get on the other side of that Shit when I Sang,
thank you.
Good night on March 5th.
Then I'll have to do is worry about wrapping up the writing on season four of f
is for family and I don't have shit until the summertime and I'm just going to
be fucking hanging in Cali doing,
you know,
getting ready to do my new hour work.
Am I,
that's,
that's the game plan.
All right.
Because,
uh,
I love my daughter and I,
I don't like leaving the way I used to,
you know.
Do you know she,
she tried to get out of her bed.
I saw two months ago she was swinging her leg up and over the,
the the crib.
Yeah.
And my gut said,
you better put some pillows down around the floor in case she goes up and over.
And I just,
you know,
I didn't listen to my gut like a fucking idiot.
So it was coming home from the,
that amazing shoot that I was on that I can't wait to fucking tell you guys
about,
but I'm just not allowed to be so awesome.
Um,
but uh,
I came home last night and you know,
after I got off set,
I never bring my phone down to the set or a watch,
you know,
cause I don't want to know what time it is because then it just makes it drag.
So I just focus on whatever the fuck it is I need to do.
And then I come walking out at like one in the morning,
however it works.
Anyway,
some fucking coming back.
You know,
I come outside and I get the,
uh,
oh,
the pizza's here.
Um,
I get this text message
and uh,
yeah,
it says we're at the emergency room,
blah,
all this fucking shit.
She fell out of the bed
and I'm like,
Oh my God,
I'm wiped out and I have to go to the emergency room and my fucking tires has a
slow leak on the left side.
So I'm like,
great.
It never rent.
So I'm on my way there.
And it's so funny,
like how my wife is wiring and how I'm wired.
Like my wife is wired like a normal,
caring human being.
And I'm like a fucking lunatic.
I was raised the way I was raised just in a different time.
So
I call her up,
she goes,
I go,
oh,
is she talking as she fine?
Yeah,
she's fine.
She's joking around,
she's laughing.
She actually didn't even cry until I came in the room and cried.
Um,
and she sent me a picture,
you know,
and I'm driving and I'm looking at it,
like I shouldn't be.
And I was just like,
yeah,
she's fine.
Yeah,
She's got a bump on her head.
She's,
she's gonna be fine and blah,
blah,
blah.
And we both had the exact opposite.
She's like,
I'm not bringing her home until a doctor looks at her.
I'll never forgive myself.
And I'm like,
I'm,
she's fine.
She's fine.
So we walk up to the window to see where we are.
It's like fucking one in the or midnight and thick and there's all these fucking
people there with their kids and they're all screaming and crying and
they say we're 16th in line.
It's just like they're going to get to us to like fucking three in the morning,
you know,
she's fine.
I literally,
I remember being a kid swinging on these ropes.
My other brother was on another rope and we went right by each other and then
slammed into the backs of our heads,
like slammed into each other.
Like I,
I saw stars that all went white and I landed face down on the ground.
All right.
I was out.
Like I was conscious when I was on the rope and when we hit,
I was unconscious than I hit the ground.
And you know what my dumb ass did an hour and a half later got right back on
that fucking thing.
And my other brother did too.
And I remember the looks on our faces when we passed each other going,
how are we really gonna do this again?
And Bam,
back of our heads again,
saw lights knocked out,
hit the ground,
you know,
and I was fine,
so fuck it.
So I convinced her that she was all right and she was all right.
But like I've kind of realized in that like I need to like a kind of gauge that,
because you know,
I came from a house where like I had a ruptured appendix at one point and my
parents like,
you fine,
you fine.
Finally went to the hospital,
they slice me,
open it at all.
Like my whole belly was just fucking pos like JJ priced.
Um,
so whatever you can take that,
rub some dirt on it too far and then he can go the other way where every time
somebody has the fucking sniffles,
you taken beyond the Goddamn hospital.
You know what I mean?
But I think my wife was right to take her down there,
but she was okay.
And she woke up today and then not on her head was a lot smaller and a,
you know,
every kid has to have their black I picture,
you know what I mean?
Um,
something that you did.
So,
uh,
it was cool and I was so proud of her that she didn't cry and she was,
she's a little toughie,
you know,
she's a little Badass.
So anyways,
you know,
she's talking up a storm and I got my little book and I try to keep up on all
the things that she says,
you know.
Um,
you know what's funny now is,
uh,
they have a park nearby and like once a year they just,
little carnival thing comes by and they have like little pony rides and stuff.
So I took her over there,
you know,
it was going on like all the little kiddie rides with her.
It was awesome.
And,
um,
and then she saw the horses.
She's like horse horse,
you know,
she knows how to make the noise and shit.
And,
um,
they had a little pony rides or you want to ride the horse?
She goes,
yeah,
righto.
Bride,
horse ride horse.
She was all about it.
Right.
And then paid the ticket.
I'm going in.
I was like,
wow man,
she's so brave.
You know,
Right.
And uh,
and she was all about it and right as I went to put her down on it,
cause they gonna put you down and then they'd like put this little safety
harness and then you as the parent walk along it,
right.
I went to center down in the second,
I started centered down,
she's going,
no,
no horse,
no horse.
So I immediately got her out of there cause I didn't want to have her to have
issues with horses.
Speaking of horses,
one of the actors that I worked with that,
um,
you know,
all of this shit I'm not allowed to say knows a thing or two about horses.
And I somehow asked them,
what does that,
uh,
road rode hard and put up wet.
What does that expression mean?
Or,
uh,
you know,
there's a couple of different ways to say it,
but that's basically,
it rode hard and put up wet.
He goes,
that's actually talking about horses and it's kind of a human cell.
Somebody like Jesus Christ,
that guy looks rode hard and put up wet.
Um,
and it basically was,
I guess if you ride a horse hard enough that it's,
it's breathing hard and it's sweating and you just where to then just walk it
into a barn,
I guess they get like these stomach cramps or something.
They call it colic or something and they literally lay down in the ground and
they flip around or I don't know what happens.
Something gets twisted up and they just fucking die.
So what you have to do is after you wrote him hard as you have to walk a horse
around until it slows,
slowly cools back down again so it doesn't get those cramps.
And if you put it into early and it lays down,
you've got to fucking get that thing back up or it's going to die or whatever,
you know,
fucking horses,
man,
they really temperamental.
So I had no idea about that shit.
So,
you know,
these are the things that you learn about.
Well,
you sitting there,
you know,
I learned all of this Shit I learned about,
there was an old school guy,
they're telling me about different actors and how much of the,
how much land they owed out owned out here.
Okay.
You know,
like this,
this actor went out and he bought from this street to this street,
which would you,
I mean if somebody went to buy that same parcel land today out here in La,
like I don't even have to be $1 billion or something in the person bought it for
like five grand.
And then for the rest of their acting career,
they just sort of slowly sold it off and made all this money is his fucking like
la is one of the most amazing
like historic cities.
If you can somehow find out what the fuck happened,
cause God knows it's not in any books because they don't give a shit out here.
They just fucking paved shit over.
Um,
it's one of the shady goddamn place.
Awesome.
I fucking love it.
But it is so fucking shady with,
you know,
we used to have street cars and trolleys and all of this fucking shit.
And then one day,
you know,
the,
allegedly this group of people got together,
you know,
that was allegedly the automakers and,
and,
and the Goodyear tire people got together and they bought up the trains and the
trolleys and they just ripped up all the fucking tracks and turned it into this
fucking mess that it is now.
Now you've got a Elon must dig in the fuck.
You know,
he's,
he's already dug this tunnel underneath la in the people that live in Beverly
hills are so fucking rich.
They stopped Elon Musk
who's powerful enough to just start drilling underneath the fucking city.
And they're powerful enough to be like,
we do not want those commoners
taking public transportation under,
cause they know what's going to happen is eventually there is going to be a
subway stop in Beverly Hills.
And they're like,
oh no.
Oh No,
no,
no.
We have not worked this fucking hard in our lives to keep these fucking,
to kick,
to get away from these fucking people,
to have them then just get on some magic carpet ride underneath the fucking
surface of the earth.
Tesla style zero to 60 in one point something seconds.
Fuck you.
You're not doing it right.
So they stopped it
fucking,
I mean,
you can't do shit in Beverly Hills.
They like,
fuck you.
We're there.
They're like their own city.
They do whatever the fuck they want to do.
They fucking do it.
Um,
you know where I live.
It's just like,
hey,
we like that.
Fuck you bulldozers coming.
Um,
anyways,
I've got a bunch of ad reads I got to do here.
So let's see.
Let's see if I can fucking knock these out here.
Oh.
Indochino
talk about how every man looks better and feels more confident when he puts on a
suit.
Well,
yeah,
if you're,
everybody does cause you're dressing up,
you know,
and if you're fat,
the sport coat really hides a lot of pounds to a certain point.
You know what I mean?
You know,
if you look fatness suit,
you just got to get on the God damn treadmill.
This is just tough love.
Okay?
Lay off the Sherry's berries.
Start crushing the water's eating some salads.
You know what the fuck to do?
It's going to melt right off you.
That's it.
You know,
cause I got to tell you,
with global warming,
I mean these fucking polar bears are going to start migrating south and you know
they're used to eating fat seal.
So who the fuck you think they're going after first?
All right.
And Yeah,
you're big thighs rubbing together as you're running in your fucking slacks.
Indochino is the world's most exciting made to measure men's wear company.
Uh,
they make suits and shirts to your exact measurements for an unparalleled fit
and comfort.
Here's how it works.
Visit a stylist at your show at our showroom and now them.
Take your measurements personally or measure at home yourself.
Shop online@indochino.com choose your fabric inside now.
Choose your design customization.
Submit your measurements with your choices.
Relaxed while you're suit gets professionally tailored and mailed to you in a
couple of weeks.
Uh,
this week my listeners can get any premium.
You know what they don't make anymore.
You know,
those really shiny fucking suits and those good fellow suits.
It's like you're wearing a suit.
That's all you need to do.
What the fucks with the shine on it.
Uh,
this week my list was fucking laminated.
This week my listeners can get any premium indochine oh suit for $359.
That's indochino.com when entering burb at checkout,
that's 50% off regular price for a made to measure premium suit plus the
shipping is free.
That's indochino.com Promo code borough for any premium suit.
Just 359 bucks and free shipping.
A incredible deal for premium made to measure suit.
Once you go custom,
you never go back.
Um,
all right,
Robin Hood.
Robin Hood is an investment app that lets you buy and sell stocks,
ETFs,
options,
and Cryptos all commissioned free.
They strive to make financial services work for everyone,
not just the wealthy,
not intimidating non-intimidating way for stock market newcomers to invest for
the first time with true confidence,
simple and intuitive.
Clear design with data presented in an easy to digest way.
Other brokerages charge up to $10 for every tray.
But Robin Hood doesn't charge commission fees,
trade stocks and keep all of your profits,
oh,
sorry.
Does not charge commission fees,
trade stocks and keep all of your profits
easy to understand.
Chats and market data.
Place a trade in just four taps on your smartphone.
Robin Hood Web Platform also lets you view stock collections 100 most populars
and entertainment,
social media of female CEOs.
Curated categories like female CEO's.
If you're into that reverse sexist shit,
uh,
and analyst's ratings of buy slash hold slash sell for every stock.
I'll tell you guys better get on this pro guy thing.
All right.
If they're going to keep going in this fucking direction,
Jesus Christ before it's overcorrected to the point we can't get,
now all of a sudden we've got to start marching in the street.
You know,
we won't be doing that through it.
It's not worth it.
Just let them have everything.
Maybe then they'll stop yelling at us.
Learn how to invest as you build your portfolio.
Discover new stocks.
Track favorite companies with personalized news newsfeed.
A Robin Hood has giving listeners a free stock like apple,
Ford or sprint to help build your portfolio.
Sign
up@billbirddotrobinhood.com.
That's capital B I L L B U R R A.
Dot Robin hood.com.
That doesn't make sense.
Oh yeah,
it is bill bird dot Robin hood.com.
Okay,
cool.
Um,
you know,
it's taking the,
uh,
by the way,
I didn't gloat about the Patriots won the Superbowl because I still can't
believe they fucking did it,
but it does make me feel good.
You know,
after all this shit,
giant fans gave me that the new England patriots now have more fucking Tom Brady
has more fucking rings than the giants and the jets combined and the buffalo
bills have three NFL teams in the state of New York and Tom Brady alone has one
more super bowls than those three teams in their entire fucking existence.
So I'll take those two losses.
Oh,
Boohoo we only went six and three.
Sorry,
just given,
um,
fellow patriots fans some fucking Ammo.
Um,
alright,
1-800-FLOWERS by now,
most of us had started racking our brains about what Valentine's Valentine's
gift is truly going to make her day special.
I,
it just blows my mind that there's nothing in here about guys and all,
all the,
all these fucking women do is bitch.
How come I can announce on Monday night football?
I don't know,
cause you have your own fucking holiday.
Isn't that enough for you?
Uh,
with one 800 flowers.com.
It's really not that complicated.
Roses from 1-800-FLOWERS are a no brainer right now.
When you order early 1-800-FLOWERS has amazing deals on vibrant and Romantic
Valentine's roses,
bouquets and arrangements,
and more.
Starting at just 30 bucks,
29,
nine and now there are so many unbelievable deals.
Hurry to 1-800-FLOWERS.
Uh,
now roses from 1-800-FLOWERS are handpicked or picked at their peak,
sorry.
And shipped overnight to ensure freshness and,
and her amazement to ensure freshness and her amazement.
That's a weird sentence.
Gorgeous valentines bouquets and arrangements starting at 2,909 is an amazing
deal,
but it won't last.
Long bouquet prices will be going up soon.
So take advantage today.
Pick your delivery date and let 1-800-FLOWERS handle the rest.
When it comes to Valentines,
um,
you don't settle for anything less than rose authority.
One 800 flowers.com to order Valentine's Day bouquets,
arrangements and more.
Starting at 29 and a nine,
go to one 800 flowers.com.
Click on the radio icon and enter burb.
You are our order and save@oneeighthundredflowers.com code bar.
How much did they cost?
20.
[inaudible].
Um,
all right,
let's look up steak and a blow job day.
I always heard that that fucking exists.
Is that an actual day steak and a blow job?
God knows a progressive mail.
We'll take a veggie sandwich at a fucking hand job.
Um,
let's see here.
Stake in a blow job.
Alright.
Stake in a blow.
Job Day.
Sticking a blow job day is a satirical holiday creating the United States.
Yeah.
It's a male response to Valentine's Day and celebrate it.
A month later on March 14th on the day,
women are proport purported to supposedly to cook a fillet steak.
Wow.
Yeah.
Good luck getting any woman under the age of fucking 50 to do that.
The women who want to cook anymore,
I mean,
I think they do it for themselves and perform fellatio on a man in response to
postcards,
chocolate and flowers by men on Valentine's Day.
The observance has no official status of course,
being a popular Internet meme rather than an actual holiday.
But various souvenirs in video clips have been produced about it.
It was conceived in 2002 by
Dj Tom Birdsi on w FNX radio.
That's Boston.
It has been suggested that steak and a blow job day is a backlash against the
feminist movement.
Uh,
it has nothing to do with the feminist movement has to do with the for,
why the fuck are we sell?
Why do I only have to buy shit to celebrate that we're together
anyways.
Oh,
oh.
Who's coming in?
My little toughie.
Hey.
Hey Nia.
Just to let you in.
Do you know when the official stake in and Bj Day is?
Uh,
March 14th.
Right.
Beautiful.
Just like that.
See that I didn't have to say anything about feminism.
Did I?
Hi.
Gorgeous.
Now look at you.
You look like it's week two of the playoffs.
Sherry's berries near.
Talk about your plans for Valentine's Day this year.
What would you do if you weren't procrastinating?
I'm not procrastinating.
I already have a reservation that my wife made.
We're going to go out and we're going to have some to eat.
Share a personal Valentine's Day story.
All right.
I always tell this story.
One time I was dating this woman and uh,
I didn't know what to get her was like my first girlfriend.
And I went to the mall and they had these polo shirts that were on sale.
So I bought three of them for like golf shirts.
That's what I bought,
a female.
And she opened him up.
She was all excited and she opened them up and she just went like,
Whoa,
what is this?
Who would buy these?
And she got so mad at me,
she started yelling at me and I was so embarrassed that I literally sat down on
the bed like a scolded child and let her yell at me for like three minutes
before I finally got enough self esteem to tell her to go a,
to go to hell.
And then she tried to back pedal that she actually appreciated the fact that I
went in and I got her a gift.
Like it's just like,
sweetheart,
you're not buying me anything.
I know this gift stinks,
but it's the thought that counts.
Right?
Isn't that what it is?
No,
it's the thought.
The shininess and how much you spent at least three different colors.
Yeah.
Three different colored Polo shirts.
They were ugly.
She was right.
Uh,
what do you do to look good on Valentine's Day?
Well,
I get a spray Tan for one.
I put on some me undies,
the Greg Logan from the Greg Louganis line.
Um,
I get a spray on like stumble on top of my head,
put on a cumber Bun,
and then I'm out the door.
Never,
never go wrong with signature dip Valentine's strawberries dipped in milk,
dark or white chocolate.
Goodness for any discernible palate.
Uh,
that's very progressive.
Nia.
Notice the white chocolate was last.
Okay.
Although milk lightskin,
there's still,
you know,
still a little prejudice there.
It's not like it's light did,
did it?
No,
it's not.
What do you mean it's not light skin?
The color of it.
I'm talking would it be considered light skin?
You're going to try to raise,
come here.
Let me,
can I ask you a question here?
Were you offended by that Gucci?
A half a black face sweater.
I,
yeah.
Yeah.
The whole thing was just very strange to me.
Didn't you think it was a tribute to Halfmoon cookies?
I did not think that at all.
No,
I didn't think that you can.
It was black,
half a face,
half,
half black face,
black,
half phase,
but I felt triggered as a white man that they didn't recognize the half a white
face that was there.
Did you?
Yes,
yes.
I'm sure they will.
Anyways,
dipped in milk,
dark or white shop that goodness for any discerning palate.
She'll fall in love with every bite.
Top with decadent toppings,
chocolate chips,
heart and glitter,
sparkles.
Perfect companion to a candle.
Lit Dinner,
a bouquet of flowers or a night out on the town.
Arrive with 100% Sherry's,
can you say Sherry's berries?
Sherry's berries.
Hey,
hey,
go
guarantee ships anywhere nationally.
Gives sweet somethings to your long distance.
Love Valentine's Day is right around the corner.
I got you a little Valentine's Day card.
You're my buddy.
I got to buy two now.
I've got two little girlfriends here.
Go to Barry's dot com click on the microphone and enter my code.
B U,
R R at checkout.
That's B e r r,
I e s d o t c o m berries.com.
Click on the microphone and enter the code bar order today.
Oh my God.
I still have one more read here.
Lastly,
but not leastly
old zip
recruiter's.
She almost did it.
Same recruiter.
Zip.
Okay,
you're grabbing them.
She said Zip.
She didn't say zip.
Now say recruiter.
Hey,
zip recruiter sends you sense your job to over 100 of the web's leading job
boards,
but they don't stop there with their powerful matching technology.
Old Zip
say recruiter.
I'll do it.
Old Zip save.
Recruiter
recruiter.
Um,
I'll make her say zip with their power from machine to a matching technology.
Ziprecruiter scans thousands of resumes to find people with the right experience
and invite them to apply to your job.
As applications come in,
ZipRecruiter analyzes each one in spotlights,
the top candidates so you never miss a great match.
Zip Up is so effective that 80% of employees who post on say,
zip recruiter,
um,
get quality candidates through this site the first day.
And right now my listeners can try it.
Say Zip,
Zip,
Zip.
Say it.
Say Zip recruiter.
Right now my listeners can try ZipRecruiter for free at this exclusive web
address.
ziprecruiter.com/bar that's ziprecruiter.com spies slash.
Bar One more time.
Say Zip
recruiter,
that Zip,
the smartest way to hire.
All right.
Listen to this lovely music here.
Um,
and then we have another half hour of bonus material from a Thursday afternoon
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast to go by.
Thank you to everybody that I've worked with over the last two weeks on this
acting gig.
Thank you.
Everybody gave me the opportunity.
I had an unbelievably awesome time.
Um,
and I can't wait for you guys to see and I can't wait for you to tell you what
it is.
And when I do,
you're going to be like,
oh my God.
No you didn't.
I'm going to be like,
yes,
I Effient
good.
I'll talk to you later.
[inaudible]
Woo.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Belper and it is the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
February 7th,
2011 seven days into February.
I'm actually doing this Sunday night,
which is why all you motherfuckers in Europe actually got this fucking podcast
on Monday morning.
And everyone across the states got it Monday morning.
All right.
And even if you're on a fucking oil tanker in the middle of
the Goddamn Atlantic Ocean,
all right?
If you didn't have to go off and swab the deck or whatever the fuck it is you
people do out there,
you got it on a Monday morning.
So I don't want to hear any God damn bitch in this week where you could you mind
you bought e pod because it's Mike podcast.
Um,
you're probably asking yourself,
um,
why do I work in a cubicle?
But beyond that,
you probably ask yourself,
why did bill actually do one on a Sunday evening?
So it was actually there for his listeners on a Monday.
Maybe if he did that more often,
he wouldn't beat ranked number 52 on iTunes.
According to one of my listeners,
he let me know that he loved my podcast and he thought that I should be ranked
much higher than number 52.
Well,
thanks a lot.
Thanks for letting me know how far down the fucking ranks I am
when you're doing rankings,
who counts beyond the top 20?
Honestly coming in at number 73,
Mabel mill infield with her how to make a pot roast podcast every week.
She talks about how to make a podcast.
You figured it,
that would get boring way to go,
whatever made up name I said five seconds ago.
So I'm doing it because I'm fucking busy today on Monday.
Uh,
believe it or not,
I actually,
I booked some acting work.
You know,
it's a great thing,
you know,
when you,
uh,
you know,
being in this business you can watch shows on TV and be fans of them.
And actually Lo and behold,
one day I should be on the fucking show and since its inception,
this very few shows that I watch every episode of,
and I just have to tell you from day one,
I have just loved that show glee.
I mean,
it is just phenomenal.
You know,
the singing,
the dancing,
the way they stole the Nelly Olson character from little house in the prairie
made her some old content with the fucking rape whistle.
Right?
It's a great God damn show.
And evidently that they've been listening to my podcast and they can stay,
you know,
they hear that I can belt out a tune,
I can carry a tune and um,
you know,
I'm going to go on this thing a little bit Tony Bennet and uh,
I can't,
I'm,
you know,
I'm legally obligated to not say what the entire episode is about.
So,
uh,
yeah.
So I'm actually,
I'm taping an episode of Glee this week
and if you believe that I um,
I got a fucking,
I got a,
I got a wind screen to sell Ya.
Um,
yeah,
no,
I am working this week as an actor.
I'm not fucking telling you on which show.
Okay.
You figure it out.
All right.
There's only 600 channels.
You know how far into my life too.
I have to let you,
but I am working as an actor.
I'm fucking psyched because my pilot for comedy central that I was doing a with
another,
one of the funniest fucking Comedians I know did not get picked up.
That's how my year began.
Began with a little bit of hope for about two weeks.
And then the industry grabbed one of my ankles and then someone else,
he undersea grabbed the other ankle and then they drove a fucking emblem right
into my ball bag.
And it said there you got bell,
have a great fucking 2011.
You know,
and I was down on the dumps for a couple,
two,
three days.
But you know,
just like one of those old,
one of those old fucking crooners songs,
jazz,
what makes that little hack they key can and something in south day.
And everyone knows that you're fucked,
but you don't got the balls to kill yourself.
So you keep a dashing say,
can you believe I'm not on fucking glee?
Um,
I can't to go fuck yourself.
You figure it out when I'm on.
All right.
Um,
so anyways,
so this is the podcast.
So I was going to do it this afternoon and uh,
I dunno,
a day got away from me and then I was like,
wow,
the super bowls today,
so I got to make sure I do it after the Superbowl because I always talk about
sports and uh,
if you're someone who's a hates when I talk about sports,
you really going to hate this podcast.
All right?
Cause I got to talk about it a little bit.
There was the fucking super bowl and you know,
you showed up,
you sport Hayton cont didn't you?
And you sat there and you ate the fucking food,
didn't you?
And you ran your mouth during the fucking game and then you shut up during the
commercials,
right?
And then you gab with all the chicks afterwards.
I thought that that was the good one.
Can you believe they pay nine zillion dollars a second,
right?
So shut your face.
Yeah.
People will say they hate fucking sports.
Still show up to Superbowl parties.
All right,
if you do that,
you're,
you're a punk.
All right.
When I say I hate sex in the city,
I don't show up for the season finale,
you know,
I know.
Go to the movies.
They are,
that's what I should do when they make another one of those horrific movies.
Right?
Do you know,
I heard most of the budgets of those movies is,
uh,
is actually dying the pubes of the women who play those girls.
It's true.
The people out here in Hollywood,
man,
I have the fucking trade magazines at my fingertips.
I know people who are on television,
they tie,
you get the inside information here.
I can't believe I'm ranked 52 with some of these gems that I'm giving you this
week.
It really boggles my mind.
I'm going to say I'm gonna,
I'm gonna crack the top 50 this week.
I'm going to get to number 49.
What do you think about that people?
Um,
Hey,
what the hell I'm talking about?
This one's just going to be all momentum people.
All fucking momentum.
Uh,
let's,
let's talk about the Superbowl.
Shall we shot off right out of the gate?
My condolences to Pittsburgh Steeler fans.
Who is a hell of a fucking game,
a little bit boring and points,
but uh,
I think some of that was had to do with the both teams had great defenses and
the fact that Ben Roethlisberger was wearing one sneaker and one moon boot or
was that an Ugh,
I dunno what happened.
I don't know what happened to that guy,
but a,
I didn't realize that he was so fucked up before the God damn game.
But uh,
my condolences and congratulations to the Green Bay packers,
ladies and gentlemen,
there.
Fourth Super Bowl Championship.
Okay.
Combining that with nine NFL titles.
All right?
In three league titles,
giving them and overall total of 16 titles.
All right?
Nobody can fuck with that in professional football in America.
All right,
shut up.
You see over there in Europe.
All right,
we call football football over here.
Even though we had the brains to pick the fucking thing up instead of skipping
around
fucking unbelievable.
Okay?
You go over there to Europe,
they always give you shit.
[inaudible] Yo,
why you call a football my Jeremia you fucker for shut up.
You do use your foot when you kick a field goal and when you fucking kick off or
when you're punt.
All right.
Jesus fucking Christ.
It's what's called foot and hand balls out.
What the fuck was,
how come you don't call it foot and head ball?
How come you don't call it that?
Use Your fucking head over there too,
don't ya?
All right.
This smarty pants.
Um,
anyways,
sorry.
16 fucking titles.
All right.
That is their 16th title.
Saw You people there,
uh,
around the fucking league who keep looking.
I don't know.
And nobody,
I asked this question why they don't count NFL fucking titles and nobody gave me
a decent explanation.
They raise good people fucking shoved back.
Then I got shit like that.
I got shit like urge because you're do merger,
dumb shit like that.
Right?
That just made a lot of sports guys perk their fucking ears up.
Yeah,
that is right.
That he's worried he's cause the merger.
Is it?
Is that why?
It is.
It's a fucking stupid reason because nobody else did that when they had a
merger.
You know,
the NHL had six teams for fucking ever in 1967 they added the expansion.
Six,
they doubled the size of their fucking league.
No other league has done that one year ever.
Okay.
They didn't tell Montreal and Toronto to go fuck themselves with all their cups.
Montreal used to win him back.
You know when they used to play in a pond,
the Stanley Cup was the size of like a fucking shot glass.
They count those.
The fucking Chicago cubs had been waiting since 1907 I don't fucking understand
it.
It's bullshit.
Okay.
And later on in this podcast,
I'm,
you know what?
Fuck it.
I'm going to read it right now.
All right.
This is basically how it went down.
And I know why you all you fucking sports nerds out there by the way,
I want you guys to debunk my,
my,
my way of thinking here.
Okay.
Cause you look at the,
the Los Angeles Lakers to,
or their NBA championships are not even,
they weren't even one in the NBA.
They were one in a league called the BBA,
which then merged with some of that.
Then became the NBA.
I mean,
you want to talk about patting your fucking stats.
You got every at the Lakers can get away with that shit and act like they're one
title away
from the fucking Celtics.
If they can get away with that horse shit with that Hanky that they put up with
five fucking titles on it.
Right.
It's funny.
Every other championship banner they have hanging on their wall,
it just says,
you know,
NBA champion,
1980 NBA champion,
1985 right.
They just have,
it's,
it's its own flag.
Then they got this one little fucking Hanky.
Okay.
Which should be a big slice of fucking toilet paper that they got five fucking
championships on.
I think Schempp played on one of those goddamn teams.
It's fucking ridiculous,
but if they can get away with that,
I'm telling you,
I'm counting from here on out.
I'm counting NFL titles.
All right.
I'm going to start a movement.
Okay.
If I can't close down the fucking Federal Reserve,
at least I can make this thing right in this goddamn country.
Okay.
Here,
here's how it goes.
All right?
Just if you want to know Green Bay's on top.
This is how it works.
Okay.
1920s when the NFL started,
all right,
from 1920 to 1932,
they had the league championship and it was determined by team wins and loss
percentages with ties admitted.
And then in 1932 because of a tie in the final standings,
a playoff game was played to determine the championship.
And from 1933 on that was called the NFL championship game,
all right?
That's how it fucking worked.
Okay.
And all these teams,
including the fucking Steelers played and played back then.
So they had an opportunity to win titles,
which they did not.
So here we go.
Here's how it goes down in the most successful teams from back then.
All right?
Uh,
the Green Bay packers,
they won nine NFL championships in three league titles for a total of fucking
was at 93,
the one 12th.
Um,
fuck it.
I didn't put these in in,
in uh,
any sort of chronological order here,
so I just got to read them.
The colts won for NFL championships.
All right.
And then another two Superbowls.
So they got six total.
The giants won New York giants,
New York football giants,
one for NFL titles plus three Superbowls.
So they got seven,
they got seven fucking championships.
You know,
they,
they sit there and walking around
like they only got three like to hang in there with my patriots.
Then that they got twice as many as us plus one Chicago bears won nine NFL
fucking championships plus one Superbowl for a grand total of a,
of 10.
Uh,
the cardinals,
I've lost,
this is why I'm ranked number 52.
I've lost so many listeners at this point,
but don't give a fuck.
Chicago cardinals,
which then became the Saint Louis Cardinals,
which then became the Arizona cardinals.
They won one league in one NFL title.
And if you want to go to an Arizona cardinals game,
and if you want to fucking chant a year at those fucking retired George
Mcgovern,
Republican conce a 1947 that's the year you want a chance at them.
1947 right?
The lines one for NFL championships,
I forget when the last one I have the wrong year.
Written down was 1950 [inaudible] Cleveland Rams,
which then became the La rams in 1946 and then became the Saint Louis Rams in 19
fucking 95 I know,
I sound like the rain man.
They have one three NFL championships plus one Superbowl for a grand total of
four.
Here's my favorite one.
And the Cleveland browns they want for NFL titles.
All right.
And before that,
they weren't for all American football conference titles.
All right.
And there were three teams that were in the All American football conference
that merged with the NFL in 1950 and I'm not counting those championships,
by the way,
the all American football conference.
I wouldn't count those because that wasn't in the NFL.
That would be like the Lakers counting those BBA fucking championships.
Um,
the all American football concert conference existed from 1946 to 1949 they had
four championship games and the fucking Cleveland browns when all four,
they dominated that league,
that league merge with the NFL in 1950 and they took three teams with them.
The browns,
the cults,
and the 40 niners.
All right,
we're continuing and we've got a couple more here.
The Philadelphia Eagles,
one,
three,
three NFL titles.
Last one's 1960.
That's what you want a chance at those angry bastards.
And then good luck to you after that.
40 niners one zero and five Superbowls,
Steelers one zero NFL titles and have six Superbowls.
So there you go for all you sports nerds out there.
That's the deal.
All right?
So I don't want to fucking hear any of this.
Any acting like those things don't count.
They do count.
That was the best of the best back then.
And they went through all the same bullshit as every other fucking league with.
Oh,
but they didn't let black guys play back then.
So what,
so what?
Every other sport counts,
those fucking things.
So,
um,
I didn't want to help.
My goddamn point was,
but,
uh,
you know what I did want to read to continue with,
I'll get back to the stats in a minute,
but can I,
Hey,
can actually bring up something here about the super bowl.
Um,
what was going on with the beginning
of the game this year with those fucking whaling whores that they brought out to
sing every song that,
that ever about America.
You know,
they brought that chick from fucking glee who tried to make America the
beautiful,
sexy.
Yeah.
Well,
what,
what is it?
Oh,
our singing amazing grace.
Amazing grace.
They get a little as they slide into the fucking line.
All right?
She should have been booted right in the box and a Christina Aguilera,
right?
Then she comes out with their booze face.
Say,
that's why I let I've been laying off the booze,
man.
That's it right there.
That's not baby weight.
All right.
That chick likes or bear.
She came out there and,
uh,
I loved her though.
I like how she sort of freestyle the national anthem.
You know what I mean?
Who can honestly remember those words and let's just sing it with somebody else.
That's a really difficult thing to do.
She was just out there and this
stars then the free no.
Yeah.
Hey could talk
[inaudible] let's go.
[inaudible]
something else.
American.
And the flag was still there.
Um,
so what,
I mean,
how long did that,
you know,
what kills me was I looked on my cable thing and it said Super Bowl pregame.
All right.
Out here,
the super bowl comes on at three in the afternoon.
So I see from fucking like 12 noon to like three is the pregame.
I don't want to see that shit.
I don't give a fuck.
I don't give a shit.
I don't really see people break down the game.
The keys to the game.
I could give a fuck.
All right.
They're never right.
I don't give a shit.
I just don't care.
So I'm like,
okay,
the game starts at three and then I go to put it on.
And what do they have more of this pomp and fucking circumstance.
And I don't like how they got to sing like 58 songs about fucking,
I understand that it's in America,
it's obnoxious.
Jesus Christ with the fucking songs and then the,
and then they got to make them laugh every time you think they're done,
they got to add a couple to the fucking line and you just sit there and I don't
get it.
It's the most important game of the NFL season and they just drag out one douche
bag after another.
It has nothing to do with the game on.
By the time the game starts,
it's like,
I don't even give a shit,
you know?
Um,
but at least Deion Sanders dressed up for the game.
Jesus Christ,
man,
that guy really was showing his age.
How can you be that flashy and fuck up that bad?
You know what I mean?
It was like he picked out that shirt and tie and right before he went out there,
somebody coffee all over it.
I think he had like a white suit and then he just went to the nearest like tire
salesman,
Eh,
you know,
once you give me a,
excuse me,
this brown suit,
I'll just put it over this,
uh,
this candy canes striped shirt with the fucking tie.
Um,
anyways,
let me,
let me get,
let me get to some stats on the past fucking week here.
I actually,
I actually took the Steelers in the over just cause I knew everyone was going to
pick the packers in the under.
I don't even know what the fuck was.
I lost 25 bucks.
That was my big thing.
You know what?
This is the first time the fucking podcast officially hit a goddamn speed bump
here.
All Right,
Bill,
I'm emailing you.
So we didn't my stats last week,
how many times I said fuck on the podcast.
This was pretty staggering.
So bill,
I email,
I'm emailing you to inform you that I served as your personal status Titian
statistician during your previous podcast on January 31st,
2011.
I documented each and every time you said the word fuck or some variants of the
word,
I must say,
you are in a goddamn league of your own.
Thank you.
Uh,
you're the podcasting f bomb dropping equivalent of fucking wilt Chamberlain in
1962.
Um,
all right,
let's get to,
um,
anyways,
he said,
uh,
it's kind of ironic that a patio in the back in a way for this feat because the,
through a little research I discovered that you used to pride yourself on a
clean bit during the early stages of your career.
Yeah,
I did.
I had to figure out if I could be funny without Carson.
Now once I proved to myself that I could,
I was then free to be myself.
Um,
who's a cozy smug can't.
despite that fact,
he said,
it's obvious that you're off the wagon and fucking shit up on a whole nother
level.
Nowadays your numbers are fucking astonishing.
You might as well throw on some red,
red leather pants and a gold chain cause your volt,
you're vulgarity is reminiscent of Eddie Murphy's,
uh,
in the 1980s,
you transparent bastard.
I'll list a few of your milestones below and then elaborate on just how
revolutionary earth shattering your last podcast was.
All right.
This is actually,
I was kind of amazed by this.
Uh,
first usage of the word fuck occurred.
38 seconds into the podcast.
You hit the century mark.
17 minutes in this stat is mind boggling to me.
It took you little [inaudible],
little over the equivalent of one quarter of football to drop a hundred f bombs.
You did this almost leisurely too.
You're a fucking juggernaut.
I can only imagine the damage you do while watching a real quarter of football,
all sauced up on the juice.
So anyways,
I guess I,
I,
uh,
last week Mike podcast was 73 minutes and I said the f word 347 times.
Jesus Christ.
You used roughly a year's worth of cuss words in a little over an hour.
Come on,
dude.
If you use F word,
there's no way you say it once a day.
Um,
all right,
that's 4.753 uses per minute.
You make Andrew dice clay and Bob Saget stuff.
Look PG 13,
I'd argue that first half breakdown in the first 36 and a half minutes.
I used it 210 times in the second half.
137 look at that.
I slowed down after the all star break.
Everybody thought I was going to be the first guy to break 400 and I didn't.
Um,
so this guy actually,
uh,
made a graph of it.
First of all,
if I can figure out how to download this,
I downloaded,
I can't find it in my computer.
He has the marker with next to is the sharpie with his headphones and all that.
Like he's counting off days in prison,
345 little slashes,
they're in groups of five.
And then he compared me to some of the most vulgar movies of all time.
Um,
uses per minute.
I'd beat out Casino Martin Lawrence live good fellas,
menace to society.
Eddie Murphy delirious,
the big Lebowski and pulp fiction and then total counts of movies.
I came in second behind casino,
but in my defense that's like a two hour movie.
So fuck them.
Um,
there you go.
Is that enough stats for you in the first 20 minutes?
Jesus Christ can be ranked like 700 at this point.
Um,
so anyways,
what the hell was my,
uh,
my week,
like I got over my road aids just to let you guys know I got over it.
I,
uh,
I dunno,
it just kept getting worse till like Friday and,
uh,
it's all,
cause I forgot my vitamins.
I told you guys,
I,
I booked some acting work right for tomorrow.
So what do I do?
I'm getting ready for the Superbowl.
Okay.
My Pay Patriots got beaten by the jet,
so I don't give a shit.
Um,
and I know I said I wouldn't trach Rex Ryan,
but for some reason I couldn't resist and I had to watch his post,
uh,
game,
lost to the Steelers speech and just,
you know,
it just drove me nuts.
He was like,
you know,
a lot of people are gonna want to criticize us and they can,
but you know,
they don't have,
they don't have any.
Right.
It's just why don't they have a right,
he's like,
just team's been through a lot.
Yeah.
You created most of it with your shit-talking.
You Shit talked the whole way the whole fucking year.
And you'll get said you were going to win the super bowl.
You wrote at the side of the Pos and you didn't.
Why do you feel people don't have a right to give you shit at that point?
It's fucking annoying in your here yet.
Oh good.
You have the shame niche going to be the shame.
I'll have the same goal.
You know what I hate about that count is one year he's finally going to win it
and be like,
dude,
what?
I say what I say?
You know what you said,
rex?
The same thing you say every fucking day.
So stop acting like you called it.
I can't stand that shit that drives me nuts.
You're fucking wrong.
Just be a man about it.
Be like,
yeah,
I talked a lot of shit this year and I was fucking wrong.
So I'm here to take my medicine,
you know,
such a fucking fat bitch.
Um,
anyways,
so I'm getting ready for the,
uh,
I'm getting ready for the Superbowl and I don't give a fuck right to the
Steelers.
It's the packers.
I don't give a shit.
I can give a flying fuck about this game.
You know,
I don't,
I don't care.
Neither one of those teams has ever done anything really do the Patriots.
I guess the packers beat us in [inaudible] 97,
but who gives a fuck?
We weren't supposed to win that game.
That was Brett Farve number that young Brett Farve.
He had brown hair and then he,
he,
he threw that first touchdown pass.
Did he took his helmet off and ran and when,
yeah.
Uhuh
over to the sideline.
You remember that?
And they actually had to make a rule that you can't do that anymore because he
was so blatantly trying to get some sort of,
yeah.
National,
commercial.
Woo.
Um,
yeah,
I'll tell you,
he just loves the game.
That guy just loves playing the game.
Oh,
how funny was it when the big Lebowski guy with the fucking most insane mustache
ever when he did those voiceovers people of Pittsburgh,
are you tired of them acting like people still work in steel mills out there?
You know,
cause I have to admit as,
as a a fan from Boston,
anytime they do anything about New England,
they show a lighthouse and a fucking lobster fishermen.
And I lived there for 27 years and I never met anyone who worked in a fucking
lighthouse,
ran a lighthouse or even worked on a fucking lobster boat.
Nobody,
you know.
And I didn't like clam chowder.
I thought it looked like a,
it just looked like a curdled milk.
Get Out.
Look Gross.
I didn't like it.
But yeah,
they're just sitting there talking about Pittsburgh going,
yeah,
this,
we're Pittsburgh's a tough town built on steel.
And when you're Pittsburgh,
if you get hit by a bus,
your mother calls you a faggot.
Right?
Sorry,
I got a little bit of the aids left.
Um,
I,
I fucking hate that shit.
And then they go up green bay,
green
basis.
Same Shit is itself a can place.
People used to pack shit up in Green Bay and Green Bay when this pack and it'd
be done.
You don't have to look too far to find somebody to Pax Upton.
You know.
I just wish they would be more honest.
You know
this place used to have a bunch of steel mills.
Now they all closed down,
they're all rusted,
half of got turned into malls.
Now there's a bunch of half fags sitting in cubicles looking at spreadsheets of
Wisconsin.
You got a bunch your fat fucks that are the God damn fucking pasty and they got
read shit on their face from the goddamn cold.
Ain't shit been packed up here since 40 before Nafta.
They are bunch of cheesy in fat flux.
This is,
I'll let God for the love of God,
let the packers win.
Why don't they do shit like that?
Could they do that?
Then I'd watch it then I wouldn't have it on fucking mute.
You know,
it'd be a nice break between whaling whores singing songs about America.
My car cheats.
Here's a thing
that diva shit.
Ah,
cause Christina Aguilera.
How bout some P90x baby?
Good Lord.
I don't give a fuck.
She had a kid.
You're still in your 20s go hit the fuck a treadmill.
What happened?
You know,
that's the danger.
That's the danger.
You know?
That's why I'm so glad you know I had a choice at some point in my career to
become a sex symbol and I was just like,
you know what?
I'm not going to do it.
You know,
cause there's only one way to go.
Just go down.
I did people,
I actually had the opportunity
to become Hollywood's first male redheaded sex symbol.
All right,
I know what you're thinking.
What about that fucking pasty freckled last client who was on on an YPD blue
fuck this whole career up.
What about that guy?
I have been in this business since before he fucked up his career.
Do you understand that people,
do you realize on March 2nd I am going to be celebrating my 19th year of
traveling to strip malls,
making people laugh,
giggle that my little wacky view of the world,
it's pretty fucking depressing.
I can't believe it,
man.
I remember when I,
when I was,
when I was a fucking kid,
when I got in this business,
when I looked at some of them are doing it 17 years,
I used to look at him like,
dude,
fucking hang it up because it is over.
It is fucking over.
You are not making it buddy.
Okay.
Maybe that's why you're sweating right through your fucking sport coat.
Jesus.
I started in 1992 that's right.
So if there was a 17 year fucking veteran,
not Jesus,
I got to do math now.
That would be that.
That would mean they started in 1975 if I worked with somebody in 1992 when they
started in 1975 I would bitch be like,
dude,
wow.
What was that like?
What was it like?
You know?
Yeah.
Drive into F,
you know,
I don't know what,
what the fuck you guys did back then?
Flying on planes with propellers.
What,
what happened?
And now I don't know what happened.
I'm 19 years into this shit.
And I realize now why those guys 17 years in and didn't quit because when you
have a 17 to 19 year gap in your resume,
you know from the last time you actually had a day job,
excuse me.
Um,
yeah,
you're done.
You don't know what's going to hire.
What are I going to hire me to do?
Sell cars.
What have you been doing since 1992?
It was kind of,
it was kind of a country.
Uh,
I have three and a half years of podcasts where I say some of the most horrific
shit ever.
There was any sort of corporate job.
Right.
Why the hell would I want to work for them anyways?
You know,
become part of the murder or whatever the fuck it is that you're doing.
There is always some sort of killing going on when you work for corporation,
you know,
it is,
if you follow it and then you sit there lying to yourself.
Well,
you know,
I just shine the gun.
I don't pull it
trigger,
you know,
ah,
it's the fucking worst.
Um,
yeah.
So I've been doing it 19 years.
There's really no turning back for me.
And if for some reason the bottom falls out,
I don't know what I would do.
I have no idea.
No fucking idea what I would do with,
which is why I don't think about this type of shit.
So I got 19 fucking years in.
That's unbelievable to me.
I remember when I hit 10 years in,
I was like,
Jesus,
I used to look at guys like 12,
13 years in when I had like eight got man,
they've been doing it a while.
They have to make it now.
They better make it now.
It's fucking over.
Um,
so I don't know what I'm saying.
You know,
which probably brings up the question.
You like bill.
Do you think you made it?
Like what is,
what is it that makes you feel like,
you know what,
I,
I think I did.
I did write the fuck.
I didn't have high look.
I must fucking see student.
Okay.
So my goals aren't that high.
I look at it like I made that book glee this week.
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
I gotta get a puppet people.
I got to do it,
man.
I gotta make it.
I have one year to make it.
If I don't fucking make it in the next year,
20 fucking years in,
I'll tell you right now.
You better build an extension to your Goddamn cubicle people cause I'm showing
up now.
I can't do it.
I left the program.
I'm like fucking uh,
uh,
what's his Marlon Brando's character in a Papa Parker Lips.
Now I'm all the way up the river.
It's over.
All right.
I got a head on the stick.
There's no fucking way.
There's no way I could ever go back in and get a real job.
I'd have to have a kid and be like,
I'm doing it for him or her.
Right.
That's the only way I could,
there's no fucking way I could go in there and have somebody.
Oh,
Bill,
all my notice.
You came in at nine oh eight this morning.
Yeah.
Did you,
did you notice anything else?
Like how fucked up that tires you have?
Like immediately I would just go to that.
Actually.
I wouldn't look at me,
try to paint myself like I'm a bad ass.
I wouldn't,
I'd be like,
Oh yes.
So I immediately go into that traffic and you know,
just become that guy and hate myself and take it out on some sweet lady of work
next to me.
He's been with the company for 25 years,
you know,
she's never missed a day.
Yeah.
It's cause she's stealing from the company.
You dumb fucks.
Um,
she's too afraid to take a day off.
Do you ever think about that?
All right,
let's get,
let's get to some topics there.
So once again,
congratulations to the Green Bay packers.
All right.
Up there in Green Bay,
when you live off water,
the Great Lakes,
you better take your Dick and wrap it around your balls because there,
there no room for pussies.
Sorry.
Um,
I better serve my voice.
See,
this is,
this is a type of self sabotage and that's been part of my career for the last
19 years.
I do shit like this.
I should,
you know,
I should've just be thinking of myself and say fuck you guys in the 52nd rank
podcast on iTunes.
I should be resting up on my voice.
That's what I should be fucking doing.
But I'm not,
I'm not,
this is,
this is what I,
you know,
I don't know why I just had a thought.
Oh,
I,
this is my thought I had.
So I'm getting ready to go super bowl right and don't give a fuck about in the
team.
And so I'm going to go make a couple of burgers.
So I've been using this natural goddamn charcoal,
which is great.
Doesn't have that chemical shit on it.
You know,
you know that shit when you're really hungry,
if he,
if you use that,
that match light stuff is,
you throw the Patty on too early at your tastes,
the lighter fluid fluid in,
in,
in your burger.
Um,
so I'm using the natural stuff,
which takes longer to light and it's more of a pain in the ass when you get down
to the bottom of the bag.
The pieces are too fucking small or he got one giant piece.
So I take out one giant piece.
It's like I'm not breaking this motherfucker up.
Long story short,
I couldn't get any sizzle,
a mark resole.
All right.
And I'm starving.
So my girls like,
well,
why don't we just make it?
Why don't we just make it on,
on the,
on the stove top.
It's like,
I'm like,
because I'm a man.
That's why,
because they can't admit the feet.
I can admit the fact that what I'm doing,
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing right now.
All right.
So I just added more fuel to the damn fire.
So then they throw these fucking patties on
is what I do.
And uh,
I make these two fucking things.
I melt the cheese and I think everything's going on right now,
but I'm doing it like I had some sizzle on my [inaudible].
You like that?
That's where a little hip hop night for this week.
And evidently I didn't.
So I,
I,
you know,
rather than cutting in and making sure everything was done it then they just
take these motherfuckers off.
Okay.
And they're like the size,
you know,
twice the size of Mcdonald's burgers.
It's just the little ones.
I don't give a fuck.
Right.
So I take it off the grill,
I put what I put on my burgers,
which is just catch up and pickle.
They keep it fucking simple.
Alright.
Slice the motherfucker and half.
And I look in the inside of it looks like raw meat and immediately my brain
goes,
don't eat that shit.
Okay,
you're going to get a call.
Like you have to take glee
tomorrow.
How can you sing with a deadly virus society?
You,
you just got overrode age.
Okay,
let's not had a cold light to this for.
What do I do?
I don't give a fuck.
I just eat the gut damn thing.
You know,
eight the fucking thing.
I smell like smoke.
I got,
I'm taking a shower and I'm in that just waiting for this feeling of fucking
death.
You know?
Fortunately it never hit me,
but you know why?
Why,
why would I do something like that?
Self sabotage.
Stupid,
you know,
that's why I never booked an episode of Caroline in the city.
I mean I booked one but a a,
you know I fucking night I got Sam and um,
all right.
You know what people that story wouldn't know where I'm up.
I apologize.
So you know,
I think it's time to bring a guest onto the show.
I'm going to hit pause here on the recording cause I've got to set up the
microphone.
We're going to bring my lovely girlfriend and,
and she's going to contribute on this week for [inaudible] of um,
is it racist,
racist,
racist?
Yes.
Ladies and gentlemen,
it is time.
Once again for,
is it racist,
racist,
racist?
Yes.
Um,
and this time,
this time I am joined by my lovely girlfriend,
Nia.
How are you sweetheart?
I'm great sweetie.
How are you?
I'm fantastic.
Let's not be too nice to each other.
Okay.
Because of my listeners,
you know,
I find out this week I'm ranked 52nd on the podcast on iTunes.
Out of how many?
Like 63.
[inaudible] no,
I don't.
I don't know how many there are.
I know everybody has a pot.
You're getting there,
baby.
See that?
All right,
well here we go.
We're gonna.
We're gonna bring you in here and uh,
and I,
you know,
you gotta hand it to me,
Huh?
Um,
for what?
Well,
you know,
I booked glee this week.
Oh,
that's right.
I know.
I'm so excited about that.
Now I'm nervous about my dancing.
I'm all right with my singing.
The,
the,
no,
we've been working on your pot of arrays,
so I felt pretty confident.
Fuck that.
There we go.
All right.
Uh,
this guy wrote from our Byu.
Are you familiar with Byu?
Brigham Young University?
This is the Mormon.
You know those people,
right?
Yeah.
They're wild and out out there.
Right?
While an hour while I'm out,
they have like 12 wives each skirts down to their ankles,
skirts down to their ankles,
and they don't lose up to their chin.
Yeah.
They're all versions before they get married vaginally.
Right.
Let me just have anal.
That's how they do it.
That's your tie,
everybody that the salt flats.
And you've seen that fucking sit that state.
All right.
Byu Is this racist?
He says,
Bill,
is it racist to root for Byu?
This is the college because they have the best scorer.
Glen Falls,
finest white boy.
Uh,
they start four white kids in total in our eighth.
In the note in the,
because
I do so evidently this guy's white and he's rooting for,
uh,
this white basketball team.
Basically they start four white guys and one of the highest number one scores in
a league is white and he's white.
Is it rate?
Is it racist?
Racist.
Because why don't you just use the effect of your garage band?
Because it takes too much fucking time.
Um,
plus I think it sounds better.
Braces.
Yes.
Yes,
yes.
See,
I can do it.
Um,
is it racist that a white guy is white for white people on a white team full of
white people?
Do I invite things playing white beliefs?
Play basketball?
No,
it is not racist.
Is Not Racist.
Okay.
And why?
Because it has nothing to do with race.
It's not like he's saying that it has everything to do with race.
It's not like he's saying like,
you know,
fuck black people.
They can't play basketball is white people.
White people own,
that's what it is.
You know?
It's not like that.
He just likes the white people.
This is what,
this is what I think.
I think if you,
if your people traditionally shock at something or have been prevented from
doing something,
then it's okay for you to root for your guy.
Okay.
Now that is nobody prevented.
Why people from playing basketball.
We just sort of sucked at it for awhile.
I don't understand why cause we can't jump.
No,
no,
no.
I'm,
I don't understand why he thinks that that would even be in the racist category
because we get in trouble for everything because he's rooting for it.
He's like,
I like this team.
I'm rooting for them,
but I don't want people to think I'm racist.
No,
it's because,
look,
if you're fucking 30 years or younger,
you don't even remember white people doing a 40 years or younger,
you don't remember is dominating any fucking sports other than hockey.
Right.
All right.
And we're starting to creep in on that a little bit that,
you know,
black people is like,
it's like,
well Brian,
when Lebron talks about the scoring title,
yeah,
I remember that.
Well you don't watch sports,
but like Lebron was just like one time they were asking him about the scoring
title.
They were like,
you know,
what are they about Kobe?
And he said,
look,
if I wanted to,
I could win that fucking thing.
But he's trying to like,
like I look at,
I look at hockey the same way like a black people want it to.
If you want it to,
we could dominate hockey.
You could,
I don't know,
you know?
I mean,
how would we know how many calls?
How many more sports examples do you need?
How many more sports do you have to fucking take over before you just sort of
realize,
you know,
you're killing it.
Yeah.
Now that,
that,
that is not racist.
Yeah.
I don't think it's racist either because we've been getting dunked on for
fucking,
yeah.
I you wants to rule for white people.
That's not racist.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right,
so there we go.
That's,
that's the first one.
All right,
next one.
This is,
this is a good one here.
Uh,
racism or ethnic than I fucking now copy that ethnicity.
That's
not what I did this after the super bowl.
I got Ecolab and recovering from road aids here.
Bill,
I've been listening to your recent podcasts about racism and had a few questions
pop in my head.
Why do they call your background,
your ethnicity?
Example?
Spanish,
African American,
Chinese.
But why?
When we tee someone's ethnicity it's called racism.
Maybe it should be called ethnicity or ethnicity.
I don't know what he's basically saying.
There is a why if I guess if you go,
I don't like those German motherfuckers.
Why would that be considered racist and shouldn't that be,
that'll be more of an ethnic thing cause they,
are there a certain brand of white people?
I honestly don't know.
You don't
on understand status question?
No.
I think I'm a little stumped too.
Like I don't know that I know the difference necessarily between ethnicity and
race.
All right.
Well why don't I know that.
I Dunno.
Why will tell me,
okay,
well racist,
like,
like a would be like,
um,
uh,
here we go.
Uh,
black people,
white people like look people fro,
okay.
People from England,
France,
Germany,
all of them.
Those are white people.
Oh,
okay.
But the ethnicity,
your ethnicity as German?
Irish.
I'm German,
Irish,
Scottish,
English and French.
My ethnicity is like African and like a small,
small drop of native American or something.
You Go.
Okay.
So what was your race?
Racist.
Black,
like I guess basically or African American,
whatever.
Whatever the fuck you fill out.
Right.
Okay.
I guess you say it a lot of times that,
uh,
I don't know what the fuck he saying.
I think he's saying like if someone like was given shit about Irish people,
they say it's racist or something like that.
Oh,
you're making fun of the ethnicity,
you know,
cause you're not trashing all white people,
right.
You're just,
you're just complaining about a certain ethnicity.
Right.
As opposed to entire race of people.
Caucasian versus Irish or something.
Yeah.
I don't fucking know.
I'm trying to get some fire on this topic.
[inaudible] get you to fucking artist.
You just agree with all of this shit.
I'm not agreeing with it.
I just,
I don't know why they,
I don't know why that it's called that either.
Well you thought my older Asian game that I play,
you said that that was racist,
right?
Yes.
How,
how is that racist?
Not The old part.
That's ageist,
but um,
yeah,
cause you said that all Asian people can't drive.
I don't know.
I didn't.
Yes you did.
When did I say that?
You always say that I didn't.
I said if somebody fucks up in front of me,
those are the two.
I'm guessing you don't see how that or Asian,
you don't see how that you're taking like one group of people in stereotyping
them.
Yes,
I'm definitely stereotyping them.
Oh,
I see.
But what you're saying is that you're not like I'm noticing Asians are bad
people that Duh,
Duh,
Duh.
Just saying that they can't drive.
So your stereotype,
no,
no pain.
So in the question makes a fucking,
you turn on a highway.
If it's not an 85 year old guy,
if you had to take your life savings,
I'm not even saying it's going to be an Asian guy.
What if you had to bet?
Right?
And if your life was on the fucking line telling you,
I know,
I know in the grand question of his bill burr racist against Asians,
I would say no,
but he does stereotype them really,
really badly.
And who's fault is that yours?
No one isn't.
Do you think I just pulled that out of fucking,
if someone said that white people can't jump,
do you think they just pull that out of their fucking ass?
Don't how many fucking white guys do you have to walk?
How many six foot 10 inch white guys do you got to watch slam the ball under the
front of the rim and almost dislocate their shoulder trying to dunk on a fucking
breakaway before you can say white people can't jump that you go on Youtube.
I mean go on youtube and you'll see some white dudes doing some shit.
Yeah,
white people could do buys.
Ryan,
you think your thing?
There are the exception and not the rule.
I'm just saying that if somebody said to me who wasn't white said,
white guys can't jump and they can't fucking dance,
I'm really not going to get into a heated debate about that.
Right.
I'm sure Donny Osmond can cut a fucking rug with John Travolta.
Oh,
whoever the fuck you want to talk to them in federal line.
He was a dancer.
Yeah.
That doesn't count.
Before he became a meeting.
It wasn't though.
He hung out with,
he hung out with black people and he did hip hop dancers.
He bought one of those VHS tapes.
Video.
He had cornrows.
Yeah.
And he liked to bang that girls.
That doesn't count.
It doesn't fucking count.
Justin Timberlake.
I mean,
ah,
stole Michael Jackson's voice and all the shit that Michael Jackson actually
stole from Mimes in hip hop dancers
and James Brown.
James Brown.
There you go.
I don't fucking,
I'm just talking shit in here.
Um,
all right,
well,
I see the distinction,
but it's still,
it's still wrong.
What is wrong?
It's wrong of you to stereotype Asian people.
Yeah.
I'm not fucking hurting anybody.
It get started off.
It started off.
It was a joke in the fucking car.
I know that.
Realizing that you don't stand up.
Sit down.
Put that in.
Unless we're going to use that finger.
I suggest you put it away.
Oh Shit.
Shit.
That's for like second grade.
What do you have on boots right now?
It's really annoying.
Why are you in your underwear?
You want to talk shit cause it's fucking 10 o'clock at night and I'm in my own
goddamn bedroom.
If you were going outside that would make sense.
You're wearing tidy whities but they're black.
I'm not.
These are,
these are like the snug ones.
They're like biker shorts.
Yeah,
they cut my balls.
They make them feel good.
What's wrong with that?
You said you like these and you were wearing your Boston Bruins.
Should I do like them?
Yeah,
but you got a lot of nerves standing up pontificating and your underwear.
Why cause a hell areas?
It shows you how passionate I am about my opinions.
I want to bribe one of your listeners,
so like send me something like an Amazon gift wish,
like a gift wishlist and I'll send them a picture of you right now as you are
going to do that.
Yeah,
go ahead and do that.
Let's see any of your fucking,
anytime you want to fucking have meals,
they don't need it at this point with technology.
They just take my hands sticking on somebody anyways.
Oh,
that's true.
Yeah.
Which is what they're all going to do now.
Thanks.
Thanks Neil.
Anything else you'd like to add,
Kim?
So you guys will somebody please do that,
may composite of that and email it to bill and you know what this is.
I have too much control in the relationship right now.
So this what you're doing is trying to get my listeners to turn on me.
Is that what it is?
Divide and conquer or making it funny.
I thought that's what I was for.
All right.
This is why I brought that shit up.
This why stood up my underwear and I started pointing at you raising my voice.
The fuck were we talking?
We've talked about that older Asian thing and it was one of the,
we were in the fucking car and you've,
you've admitted in the car,
you're like,
Jesus Christ.
There's something to this game.
And the
time when it was a little odd,
that's the closest I'm ever going to get you admitted to your posts.
The best one was one was an old Asian guy and that's what we came up like.
That was hitting like the green double zero in fucking a roulette.
You had to call old Asian.
Well,
it's rude.
I have [inaudible] is going to sound terrible,
but I have Asian friends so I don't want people to think that I sort of,
why Kevin Shay?
Bobby Lee.
Oh,
I love Bobby Lane.
You don't love Kevin Shay?
I don't know him.
Really?
Bobby Lemon.
Kevin Shay is like the angry Bobby Lee.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
Got It.
Bobby Lee's anger is just somewhere hidden in there.
Fucking Jesus Christ and yet,
yeah.
You know what this is.
This is right here.
This is why.
You know what it was,
is when you,
when you,
when you want to break balls,
you got to hang out with other guys because of the woman's gonna ruin it.
What about why you want to bring in a little nother mini bill burr and here just
your own opinion.
Regurgitated over and over again.
Why don't you get bored with that?
With like audio of a crowd applauding underneath.
Bill's always right.
Give me another,
is it racist?
All right.
Well,
I have to look up one.
You real.
Oh,
do you realize I said the f word 347 times.
That is incredible.
Even for you.
Really?
Jesus Christ.
You just really abandoned me,
aren't you?
I'm not,
but that's excessive.
Yeah.
This podcast is
of the whole thing is fucking ridiculous.
Beard as excessive.
You're the one who told me to fucking grow it.
I love it.
He told me to grow a God damn beard like,
and guess what?
You got a part on Gleevec
because of it.
That's right.
I'm playing the part of Kenny Loggins.
Alright,
now these,
these are the ones,
I'm just grabbing these,
Eh,
uh,
I dunno where,
okay.
And this was,
this was your fucking idea too.
Cause some of these get crazy.
All right bill.
Oh No,
I'd like to get your fault.
I'd like to use your,
is it racist segment to get a ruling on a dispute between myself,
a white guy and some friends?
The issue involves,
uh,
the issue in question revolves around a particular Halloween costume of mine a
few years back.
You chose this one near,
here we go anyway.
Uh,
anyone who's been to Vegas knows about the porn slappers that clog up all the
sidewalks on the strip.
I guess those are the guys who hand out the flyers,
I guess.
I have no idea.
I'm so calls because as they're handing out the stripper,
our US business cards,
they give him a quick snap on the hand shoving them in your face.
Okay.
Is if having full color porn pushed on you while trying to walk down the street
wasn't enough,
I guess they deem it necessary to violate your auditory senses as well.
Well,
they got to get you to pay attention.
All right.
Um,
during a routine trip,
Durand's me of something,
I'm sorry that that slapping of the car that reminds me of,
remember when we went to jumbos classroom and that girl,
when we first,
when we first went in there,
the stripper was like super friendly.
So they as you walk in and then occasionally you'd hear like,
like a clapping noise.
Really loud sound like somebody got shot and it was her clapping,
her boots,
her stripper boots together trying to get your attention.
I'm like,
cause the room was too quiet and no one was paying attention to her.
It was so pathetic in there and all of a sudden it sounded like a gunshot.
Clapping her fucking
stripper quit on.
Exactly.
Anyway,
Sam never dancing and she just stopped dancing.
She,
she crawled over on her hands and knees to her purse,
light on her stomach,
pulled her phone out and started texting.
Music's still going titties out with the Thong on,
but the best part was she,
uh,
she danced to the whole first song.
Yeah.
And didn't make one dime.
It was slowly coming down.
The pole grade is lovable and then whatever the hell it was and then landed on
her back.
Not one time.
She was horrific.
She was ugly too.
And um,
the next song started and she was just laying there.
Yeah,
she didn't answer the bell like a fighter quit on the fucking school.
I had no respect for.
Um,
anyways,
let's just continue here.
Uh,
during a routine trip to Vegas,
noticing how he paints himself as somebody person,
you know.
Right.
I thought it would be funny to dress up as a porn slapper for Halloween.
So while there I collected a sizable stack of the previously mentioned cards.
When I returned home I had a fluorescent pink stripper direct to you shirt,
made a,
had it made up in assembled with other key components to create what I
considered to be an authentic reproduction.
Is this going to end with him in blackface?
It's going to end with him in Mexican face or whatever.
Cause that's all the guys seem to be like Hispanic handing those out.
I know where this is going.
Here's when the train went off the tracks and a claim
costume became racist.
My completed costume consisted of a straw cowboy hat,
short black wig,
brown facial makeup,
a large mustache stripper direct shirt,
some navy Dickies and tennis shoes.
Basically,
if Poncho villa had to get a second job to pick up a little cash on the side,
that's what I ended up looking like.
Now,
did any of my so called white friends mentioned that this costume might be
racist during the construction,
frayed or their so called white?
Are they still called friends so called white print?
Of course not.
They didn't say or basics has white friends didn't say shit,
but the second amount on Halloween night,
suddenly I'm surrounded by spokespeople for the Anti Defamation League.
Dude,
where the fuck did you do this?
My stance in all this was a yes that the costumers privately,
racially insensitive,
but it was not done to be malicious.
I was just shooting for authenticity and therefore it wasn't racist.
My friends claim that it was blatantly racist.
The friends who didn't say shit,
we're not trying to step away.
Call white friends,
so called white bread.
Um,
can I please get your opinion on this?
Uh,
all right,
here's my question.
Did he have to,
he could've done that entire costume without the,
let's say brown face without the brown phase and people would have gotten it
because he'd be heading out those thank you pages and he'll be like,
oh cause everyone's gone to Vegas.
Everyone's seen those.
I went to Vegas,
I brought you back a stack of those fucking cards cause I thought it was funny.
So people would have gotten it.
So it does seem a little excessive to add the brown face when it's unnecessary.
So he is,
he's dipping his toe in the racist pawn.
I do not think that this person is a racist human being.
I don't think he's like,
he,
he thinks Mexican people are bad.
They shouldn't,
I shouldn't even say Mexican.
They could be Peruvian,
whatever.
I don't think things are bad.
But he definitely dipped his toe in because there was really no need to go that
far.
He could've done the entire thing.
And everyone would have gotten it.
All right.
This is what I said.
He didn't need brown fee.
What I say,
I say this isn't racist.
I say,
well he's guilty of is not knowing that he was going to be called a racist
because if every fucking due to the hand in those things out that weekend was
Mexican and look like that and he went all out to try to look like that.
All he's guilty of is having a fucking kickass costume.
All right.
And if the Wayans brothers can make white chicks,
that fucking horrific horror that I fucking saw and I'd say it's up.
I didn't even see the movie.
I just like was so fucking
weird that that just got to Trans Fast Id for me when he took his foot out and
had it on the table.
It just really was fucking understand how we're supposed to believe that
everyone in the movie doesn't realize that it's black people in white face cause
it's
[inaudible].
People really believe that this isn't an actual white person.
Like they're talking to other white people.
Like it doesn't look weird and this is my thing.
If you can fucking do that.
Okay.
Which I get,
I get,
the rules are fucking different because all the bullshit,
the tablets.
So that's one of those things where he's guilty of light,
like a white person who doesn't mean anything bad but says you people are you
guys right?
And then has to be like,
well,
I don't,
I didn't know.
I didn't fucking know.
So I,
I wouldn't say that that's,
that's,
that's not racist.
It's just a,
but your friends are fucking sellouts who you think they did it on purpose.
I think they were like,
oh,
this is going to be good.
Okay.
They're on purpose.
I think they wanted him to get called out.
If they did it on purpose,
then that's fucking four,
I think.
Yeah.
I don't think,
uh,
I think it was a little unnecessary to add that.
I don't think he needed that for the costume.
This is what I would say.
In a perfect world.
He had a great costume,
but because of all the shit that we've done,
you know,
that's just one of those,
one of those extra,
you know,
because of all the extra perks,
perks you get for being fucking white.
You know,
like you should see,
you should have seen the gift bag I got when I was born.
It was,
it was fucking ridiculous.
It was like a bag full of cash.
Oh yeah.
USA Today.
College was automatically paid for it.
You had a giant up.
Oh yeah.
White people.
We just bitch cause no,
that's actually,
it's uh,
you know,
I,
if I,
if I could tell you honestly how difficult it is being white.
I want to know though,
why that,
I'd be curious to know why he felt like he had to add that to it.
He did.
Maybe he didn't feel like the costume was like clear enough.
He's like,
I got everything.
You know what this needs.
He could even just left the mustache.
And what if you're going as a specific guy like Billy crystal.
When he used to do Sammy Davis Jr on SNL was in,
he was not only in black face,
he was in black body,
black,
everything.
He went,
oh you're obviously not underneath but like he and he somehow he got away with
it cause he was doing a specific guy like how does that work?
But then Ted Danson comes out and does a roast.
I mean I'm really going far back here,
which allegedly everything goes.
Did you see on 30 rock when they had one of the characters in blackface?
They had a much,
I don't want shit.
The girl who plays Jane Krakowski.
It was really funny.
And then the context,
it made completely sense and it wasn't like,
all right,
let me,
let me read one more here and then we're going to let you go here.
Another,
another stunning performance here.
Dear Bill,
after listening,
how much better am I getting at reading out loud?
You know what I mean?
As I do now,
I'm getting way better at this for like a little kid.
I am.
What I,
what I do is when I start,
when I start to lose control,
this sentence,
I just make up
whatever they're talking about after listening to all the racist stories from
the last two podcasts.
I really like your comedy bill.
I have one.
Did they really say that?
No.
I have one I wanted to share that I have always felt I lost.
Uh,
all right.
Back in the 10th grade,
I had a friend name Robbie.
He happened to be one of the five black people in my high school.
Oh Geez.
Here we go.
I knew him for a few years and we had a few classes together.
We both took some sort of technical drawing classes and sat next to each other.
After we became sort of friends,
he thought it was okay to call me cracker Hunky,
et cetera.
This must've been the 70s.
So if he broke out Hunky,
uh,
I'm pretty sure he stopped calling me by my real name and only by my racial
slurs after a while,
seeing how I'm white and I'm pretty laid back.
I didn't give a fuck about what he called me.
Yeah.
I mean,
at that point,
if every president was white at that point,
you don't give a shit.
It doesn't carry as much water.
Suddenly was after about two weeks of being bombarded with racial slurs.
See,
I don't even consider those racial slurs.
I just consider those,
you know,
I don't consider those ratios.
Yeah.
Hey,
white boy,
that doesn't bug me.
They fucking black guy.
That does it.
It does.
It doesn't bother me.
I don't give a shit.
Um,
anyways,
uh,
after about two weeks of being bombarded with racial slurs,
I figured I would,
I would say,
oh no.
Well,
okay.
Yes.
You know what it means.
I figured that by saying it,
it would be all be in good fun and we would have a good laugh and it would be
over.
Oh,
I hope.
I hope he buried it in the middle of a sentence.
That's the only way.
If he had,
he needs a lot of words surrounding it and better known as said it with the Ar.
Here we go.
So one day a great opportunity came along when I walked in the room and Robbie
says,
what's up my cracker in my head,
I was telling myself to let her rip that's so close to get her done.
This isn't gonna end good.
So while I'm doing some sort of stupid hand shape,
I replied to Robbie saying,
what's up my n word?
Instantly without hesitation,
Robbie's incestual tribal warrior spirit kicked in.
Next thing I knew I was being manhandled by a black kid that was much bigger
than me.
Uh,
the scuffled didn't last long and nobody got hurt.
He said,
what's up my crack?
And then you said,
what's up my n word?
And that was a fan
that kind of seemed like the comedically that would flow.
Yeah.
And it would be like funny and everyone would be like,
everyone in school would be kind of like,
wow.
Like they have that kind of relationship that they can go back and forth like
that.
Well,
he's actually sounds like a really bad sitcom.
It does.
All right,
let's finish.
Here we go.
After the fight,
we got into a twisted debate on how I was somehow wrong for what I said,
Eh,
that Robbie wasn't,
it was some,
it was some complete bullshit,
like a bunch of pussies afraid of appearing a racist.
None of the other white kids in my class have my back to this day.
It still amazed me how sensitive people are when it comes to racist shit.
Robbie could clearly dish it out,
but he couldn't handle any,
uh,
heat directed toward him.
I didn't give a shit what he called me,
but,
uh,
shit right there.
I should've made up some shit.
I don't give a shit when he called me because I knew he was just joking around
when I started joking around,
he flipped out.
We still remained friends throughout high school.
To this day,
I feel as if I didn't do anything wrong,
but I still feel as if I lost the argument.
What do you think?
Uh,
I think that's one of those things where,
uh,
maybe because,
because it was too many other white people around,
but it was one of those things where he should have got at least two minutes for
instigating on that run.
You know,
[inaudible] fighting one gets two minutes for instance,
cause I can see where if they were in private they might've said that to each
other and laughed.
But if there's other people around then his friend feels like embarrassed and
humiliated and like,
oh you're letting this guy say whatever you want.
And so,
you know,
but this is like,
this kind of like reminds me of when black people say that we shouldn't be so
casual about the n word because it makes white people think that you guys can
just say it to us because we say it to each other all the time.
You guys say to each other all the time I was with the big dealers,
rappers and stuff,
you guys are constantly saying it.
So it's like now it's a problem.
If I say it very clearly not the same thing.
However,
I do see that side of the argument where it's like,
well in a lot of it's from like older black people too that are like,
you know,
you can't keep saying it like that.
Cause why people will think that we don't respect ourselves and so they should
neither blah blah blah.
Let me go back to the white guy,
go,
well what you guys say to tribal blah,
that's just a racist for the most part,
that's just a racist white guy.
Triathlon acting is rationalize saying the n word.
I'm trying to rationalize or trying to get away with it.
Yeah,
yeah.
No.
Okay.
So I would say
pretty much that's what that is.
I never a,
I don't think his friend should have opened the door to use that kind of
language.
And I think his friend was kind of enjoying the phone.
I call him,
I rang her and Honky,
I think he liked that,
that he could just say that to him.
And it might've been like some sort of subconscious like,
yeah,
see I can say whatever I want.
You can't say shit to me.
And then when he did,
it was like,
no,
you can't,
which isn't exactly fair.
Has It always said it?
If you went a little high pitched and try to say it like funny,
I think he could have
like,
what's his face?
Who you impression of the peanut here?
How does he,
how does he always greet the black guy on it?
Say the white people for us.
Be like,
Hey Sharon.
He goes,
hey,
how are you doing Villi?
How's it going?
Tommy looking good.
How you doing Nathan?
Oh,
fucking dad.
That's just embarrassing.
Oh,
speaking of embarrassing,
I asked last week who was the last white guy to win an NFL rushing title.
And I actually got two interesting answers.
Okay.
The last time a white guy won it for the conference,
Mark Van Egan wanted for the AFC in 1977 but Walter Payton one,
the overall rushing title and Jim Otis when in 1975 that doesn't sound like a
white guy named Jim Otis.
Uh,
yeah.
Oldest Anderson for the Saint Louis Cardinals.
He wanted,
and I think Oj Simpson one at that year.
Uh,
speaking of white people,
um,
I didn't know what he meant by that.
I was
just picturing his,
his,
uh,
the woman eat fucking,
oh my God,
that's married to back when that verdict was read and we watched,
we were watching it in high school and I went to,
you know,
pretty much an all white high school.
There was definitely some black people there,
but not as many as the white people.
You guys like high fiving is every other white person famous.
It was weird.
It was a weird thing because it's like,
yeah,
we were watching it in class,
you know,
when we should have been learning,
but we're watching it in class.
And then so the verdict and the like,
you can feel them wanting to sell,
like wanting to be like no.
And then them looking at me,
me and you know,
looking at maybe the other one other black boots.
And I remember this guy coming up to me,
he goes,
listen,
I'm not racist and I killed,
killed that way.
But I think,
I think,
I think he should've gone to jail.
And I was like,
ah,
okay.
And I said,
well,
he's not,
and he goes,
well,
and then he just walked away and he walked away and then probably mumbled some
other shit.
Um,
but he just felt the need to let me know.
Right.
Well that's one of those things where black people being happy with the saint,
that was just like the white guy rooting for Byu because they just,
you know,
white guys have not succeeded in basketball and you guys haven't done so well in
the trials,
have so much history.
So it was less about the fact that he clearly did it.
The fact that,
you know,
no we didn't because he wrote that book where he said,
if he was gonna do it,
this is how I would do it.
[inaudible] it's totally different.
The book never even came out.
First pack of football cards I ever got Oj Simpson was,
was,
was the,
uh,
was the first one and I fucking loved the guy.
He betrayed you guys more than he betrayed us.
Outlook,
which is,
look,
the ultimate irony.
He,
I can't even say what I,
how I feel about that shit.
But I'm going to tell you this,
there is actually a picture somewhere in the attic of my life of me in second
grade sitting on Santa Lap with an Oj Simpson Jersey.
[inaudible] that says it all.
You're on my hand cause I had a good day at school or some shit.
Oh,
I just remembered another example of,
uh,
well let me finish blackface.
Well,
let,
let me,
let me finish the rushing title and the last white guy to overall when a rushing
title like no bullshit was 1962,
Jim Taylor for the Green Bay packers and he wanted an in between,
uh,
Jim Brown.
I don't know what happened to Jim Brown that year,
but uh,
so he wanted,
so they go that that's essentially the pot.
Yeah,
a support cast for this week.
Um,
I got arrest up to do my glee this week.
Uh,
you know what Song I'm singing?
No,
what is it?
I'm too embarrassed to even say
you sensei.
Let it be as surprised.
Let it be a surprise when it's tune in.
Oh yeah,
it's,
yeah.
Ugly on the Glean Network.
And what was,
what's your last thing before I sign off here?
Cause I got to upload this shit.
No,
I'm just going to,
I just wanted to talk about really quickly.
I had a boyfriend in college.
Oh kamia.
Thanks for coming on the podcast.
We had a great time.
No,
I do have a couple more tops.
I don't even know your fucking boyfriend.
No,
it has nothing to do with our relationship.
It's when he was a little kid got up and he was dressed as a hobo for Halloween.
He was white by the way.
Um,
and he put dirt on it.
Like he wanted to put like brown makeup on his face to look like dirt.
So He'd look like a dirty Hobo.
And it looked like
black
people were like,
do you think all black people are hopeless?
And he was like,
I just want to be dirty.
So it was,
which made it worse,
but it was hilarious.
Yeah.
Geez,
that's a funny story.
It really isn't
because the fact that he told you that story,
I can see how far into the relationship you are,
which means other things were going on,
which I really didn't need to know.
All right,
here's one best teacher ever.
Listen to this guy.
This,
I got this from a teacher.
Where the fuck was this guy when I was in high school?
Hey Bill,
first of all,
love you podcasts in your stand up.
Thank you.
The reason why I'm writing to you is I'm a math teacher and I have a student
who's a class clown.
I really think he has the potential to be a great standup comedian and I want to
suggest that to him,
um,
as a potential future for him.
Um,
I don't think that academics is really his thing.
What would be some good things slash advice to show slash tell him,
right?
Rather than being the asshole teacher,
be like,
you sit down and shut your fucking mouth.
Make them clap the racist or whatever the fuck these kids do nowadays.
Um,
this guy's actually,
I'm actually brought the guy back.
I said,
what?
I always say,
write five minutes of Shit you think's funny.
Sign up for an open mic.
When they call your name,
go up on stage and there you go.
Don't judge yourself the first 10 to 15 times you do it 10 times.
I would say it's all about being like,
wow,
I'm holding a microphone.
I'm really doing that.
They really do have brick walls behind me as you're trying to remember your shit
,
but after 10 times then you start getting a feel for it and then then,
then everything else falls into fucking,
they have a talent contest at a talent show at the school.
He should do it too.
Oh he shouldn't.
That's what I need to tell you.
Under no fucking circumstances,
should you ever go on stage.
The first time you ever did stand up comedy in front of your own fucking class.
Oh my God.
Oh that's true.
Because if it doesn't go well,
it's going to be humiliating,
so he should do it somewhere else away from so he can work it out so he doesn't
bother friends.
Everybody's going to heckle you.
Reach your balls.
That that is like,
that's why like bombing on a cruise ships sucks because when you,
after you bomb,
you can't leave
with the crowd and everybody just sits there looking at you and that that's,
but at least the cruise is over in a week.
This kid's got to finish off the fucking school year.
We put the love of God.
You have to teachers listening to not tell him to sign up for a talent.
Fucking contests don't do that because that's the type of thing they could leave
and emotional scar with a kid might not do it again for five years or never
fucking do it again.
Okay.
You need,
you need an escape plan when you're going to go up and do that shit.
Believe me.
What I,
the first time I've ever fucking bombed,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
Where is the first time you bond in some fucking bar in uh,
uh,
north reading Massachusetts.
I want to say some place Kelly's or something doesn't even exist anymore.
And I walked in and there was this function,
this little half of the bar where you could sit down and eat fucking fish and
chips stowed and there was like nobody there other than other comedians.
And then like three fucking people who came to see another comedian and then up
at the bar with just guys drinking like five people spread out amongst 15
chairs.
Uri your balls.
And I didn't know how to handle it.
And I went up there and I just bombed and said,
oh,
I was supposed to do five minutes.
I bailed like two minutes in and said on the Mike,
I told you that said to the host Jack,
I go,
Jack on Balan in all the comments went ahh.
And then I felt like a fucking pussy and I want to do is just walk off stage,
get my car and drive home.
But I was so humiliated.
I sat in the first fucking chair that was open,
which was like two Rosen and just sat there with my head down wanting to leave
the whole time and sat there throughout the rest of the fucking open mic.
Like a scolded child.
And then I drove home,
cried classic German,
Irish.
Rather than dealing with the emotion,
I kept trying to put it outside of my body and it was just hanging in my car the
whole fuck.
It was horrific.
I can't imagine doing that.
And then doing it in front of your tire fucking class.
It was horrific.
So that was bad.
My bad.
Yeah.
Bad Advice.
All right,
you too.
Youtube,
youtube,
fucking videos of the week.
Uh,
this one,
uh,
Brad Garrett was on the job,
bay harsh show.
And if you just want to see a fucking stand up comedian in complete,
not giving a shit mode,
just going off.
You got to watch this.
He's absolutely fucking hilarious.
This guy is a true standup comedian.
Like I already loved them from the Ray Romano,
Chabot and I watched this clip.
This guy is the shit and I would definitely go see him do stand up.
This is what it takes to be a great comedian.
This guy completely doesn't give a fuck.
And there's a bunch of people evidently watching it cause he,
he jokes that all is Ray Romano money has gone saying he invested in,
into this comedy club.
Like he was on a hit series for fucking 10 years,
like 10 years of syndicated money.
That's how much it takes to open a fucking room in Vegas.
When you're in name,
he's clearly joking
people,
right?
Is he broke his,
he doing heroin?
Heroin?
No.
What's great is he just,
at one point he's throwing chips at people who were in Vegas and you go,
you're white trash.
You know,
he doesn't call it.
It's fucking hilarious.
You got to see itself.
All of these
we the MLM,
podcast.com.
Um,
we put this one up last week,
but I forgot the hype it insane robot movie.
You got to see this thing.
It's just a clip from a fucking great movie.
And also the greatest wrestling clip I've ever seen in my life.
Nia said she wants her five minutes of her life back.
This is the greatest thing I've ever seen in my life.
The name of the video is the most illegal thing I've seen in wrestling history.
You have to watch it.
It's fucking awesome and quick.
Overrated.
Underrated.
Um,
okay.
Overrated.
The black eyed peas,
uh,
build the black ips are terrible.
I'm pissed.
I watched that halftime,
uh,
bullshit at the Super Bowl,
even on mute with the promise that it was going to be something I didn't want to
miss.
They suck and that noise they call music is the worst crap ever.
Um,
I walk out,
I never watched the halftime shows.
They're fucking horrific.
They were very different before Fergie showed up.
And I'll just leave it at that.
Okay.
And if you know them,
you know that what I'm saying is true.
Yeah.
You're blaming the white girl.
Okay.
Is it racist race?
Car Sex?
Underrated is often unappreciated.
Lol.
There's nothing like pulling over on the side of a busy interstate and getting
it on what he says
or stumbling out of a bar with some random chick you bought a few drinks for and
convinced to leave with you going into a car and not even in,
not even making out of the parking lot.
It's just oh,
in bag and basically it's just plain awesome.
Uh,
I purchased,
let,
let it go and loved it.
Thank you.
Um,
I would say that sex in the car was way better back in the day when they had
bench seats and actually made huge cars.
But,
uh,
I think it's,
I don't know.
You know,
I don't like the look and I don't like the fucking look in your Goddamn I
um,
okay.
And I'm not getting into that pocket,
personal life,
but we don't,
we don't have enough memories.
[inaudible] wow.
Yeah.
The older cars are better because they have more room.
Fucking gotta be kidding me.
You know what?
Why don't you get your trip?
He Ass Outta here.
Please meet you think I didn't realize that when I met yet.
Huh?
You gotta realize,
you know,
you could find a sex life before you got them right.
What is the problem is when it took male whore meeting a female or you're a man
whore.
I was not.
No,
you are a man.
I was always,
I wasn't looking at me in the eye look like fucking howdy duty with a fucking,
but you've got that whole little like sexy,
angry thing going on women like this.
And you know what I'm like,
I don't like being pandering to cater to whoever the fuck.
Let's see.
Oh,
here's one last quick thing.
I always say I'm going to fucking end it.
I never do.
All right.
Corporations,
uh,
selling your information.
Hey Bill,
I did listen to your podcast for a while now and think,
ah,
they're very entertaining and funny.
I do have to admit,
however,
that every time I,
maybe I read this last week,
I can't remember,
but I'm just happy because I ended up being right here.
Uh,
I do have to admit,
however,
that every time you talk about the conspiracy theories and people tracking your
electronic purchases and whatnot,
I roll my eyes and wonder why you're so crazy.
However,
this is why I actually started reading better.
As I pause now and I look at the next three words and it fucking works out the
king's speech and what is that?
What that movie's about?
I know.
Yeah.
I'm not watching this.
It's good.
It's really,
really good.
It looks like it took place in another time.
So that automatic voice in another time.
It's a period piece about reading.
It's fucking horrific.
But that's what I was just talking about.
Whatever.
What did you think about your time in that Fucking Ltd?
Um,
however,
recently.
Ah,
that's one of my favorite cars.
You just ruined it.
You know what?
I'm going to have to tell a fucking story that's going to ruin something for
you.
Let me think.
What are you into?
Going to the mall.
Yes.
One time I got the fucking or whatever orange Julius stand.
No.
However,
recently
browsing the Internet and started noticing ads on every page that directly
related to something I had just purchased online.
How fucked up is that?
Now I knew things like this happened and that site's kept certain information
about you,
but I guess since I never saw any visual evidence of this,
I simply put it in the back of my mind.
It never worried about it.
However,
now I had direct in your phrase,
evidence of being tracked.
I have to say I felt a bit violated.
Yeah,
it's weird like somebody just sitting there watching what the fuck you're doing.
Um,
anyways,
he says,
I think that the ads were specifically being put up for me on every website I
went to struck me as a huge invasion of privacy and it was a bit on nerving.
Um,
this was a week,
two ago and ever since then I've become a bit paranoid about the amount of
information that is out there about me.
I thought about all the Times I've entered my credit card information
information or home address online in order to make some purchases and went
through every website he could think of to erase that information.
Dude,
it's overt.
It's already up there.
Um,
I know once it's out there,
it's impossible to take back,
but I have to do what I can do.
I've changed my email address,
my old email email address,
had my full name in it,
um,
started shredding everything with my address on it and started using cash only
to make purchases so that someone can't track it,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Uh,
yeah.
I actually,
somebody sent me an email the other day of some four year old kid,
got a,
um,
a,
what do,
what do you call it?
A credit card application application yet from American Express.
And why are we talking about how if you use Gmail,
if you're having an email conversation with somebody and you mentioned something
like,
Oh yeah,
I'll meet you after I go to the spa.
Next thing you know,
there's all these ads for spa stuff.
Like someone's watching it,
Google reads your email,
it picks up on key phrases,
and then just automatically pops up ads around it that you could correlate to
that email that you just,
for some reason you're looking at an email like,
like it's illegal for you to read my mail mail.
Right?
So the old school shit,
right?
But somehow online they can just look at that because it's just,
no,
it's now this is what morons are going to say.
Look Dude,
I mean,
oh,
it's just two computer program is,
she's picking up shirt and words like this.
This is how you gradually work your way to having a microchip in your forehead
is they just incrementally take away what they used to not be able to do.
And then what happens is people die off and then the new standard is where this
new generation was born.
It's like being taken off the gold standard where cash used to represent gold.
You brought your golden,
silver was heavy,
it was dangerous and it was a pain in the ass to carry around.
So banks are like,
we'll bring the shit into us.
We'll give you these pieces of paper cash that represent the gold.
You give us $20 in gold,
we'll give you a $20 bill.
And anytime you want you can come back down and fucking,
you know,
get you $20 in gold.
And after awhile we just kept using the piece of paper.
People forgot about the gold.
The fuckers who brought the golden died.
They took us off the gold standard.
Now you can't claim it.
What happened?
All that gold and silver,
those fucking can stick.
They kept it.
They kept a shit.
So that's what I'm saying about all this other stuff is like all this stuff that
you used to not be able to do like this.
People being born now will not remember a time when people couldn't just,
you know,
when the government couldn't listen to and record every phone conversation you
ever fucking had.
And I know people get like,
I dunno,
this is the type of shit you,
if you talk about what people think,
you're fucking paranoid.
Well,
it's also like,
you know,
the stuff that you put on,
like Facebook stuff,
they'll come here.
I don't care.
I'm just picturing you in a Goddamn car with your fucking hot ass feet up
against the fucking window.
All right.
Just his podcast is too God damn long at this point.
Oh,
I already did like another 25 minutes.
Other than this was like an hour and 15 minutes and cut off that part of you.
Which part?
The part where we were talking about the stuff with the cars.
Probably be the fucking best part of the podcast at this point.
All right then I look,
I got you got,
you know it's what I'm here for.
I know it's give and take.
Yeah.
Comedy.
Somebody's got to get hurt this week.
It was me
next time.
Is it going to be me now?
I wouldn't do that cause I got a fucking live with you.
Yeah,
I got to live with you.
Well that's it.
Listen,
I have to rest up my voice because I'm singing a macho man in my fucking
underwear tomorrow on glee and that's it.
Thanks for listening the podcast this week,
and thanks to each and every one of you out there for making it number 52
on the podcast.
That's right.
I don't give a fuck.
Ah,
that's it.
You guys have a good weekend.
Congratulations to Greenbay my condolences to Pittsburgh in a everyday,
but you go fuck yourself,
right?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible].